[Musica]
con le dirette palle di pelo bella a
tutti ragazzi e benvenuto e questo nuovi
ed a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo in
un nuovo blog ragazzi prima di
cominciare volevo soltanto fare una
premessa fortissima poi iniziamo giuro
allora praticamente lo scritto su
facebook anche quindi molti di voi lo
sanno
mettetevi cacia pagani facebook con
questi giorni è successo che mi son
beccato la febbre che cosa fantastica
quindi ragazzi mi scuso in anticipo
sesto blog mi sentite un po più diverso
dal solito è perché poi dato sto sta
ottenendo la fee non ho mai fatto un
video con la felpa ma sto tenendo questa
perché se metto le magliette di pavia
che di solito mettono i video tipo che
sono a maniche corte siamo in inverno
domani mi sveglio che devo andare
all'ospedale praticamente quindi ragazzi
scusatemi ma dovevo stare leggermente
più al caldo oggi perché se non moriva
tanto note filo scoperto non vi era fa
tantissimo
passando alle news era che volevo dirvi
che attualmente oggi che sa ma perché
faccio sempre così con che oggi che
sabato sarebbe dovuto uscire lo speciale
250.000 iscritti come vi avevo detto
però purtroppo ragazzi con la febbre
il tutto mi è andato contro io volevo
fare sto speciale gli iscritti a si sono
saliti di botto quindi non ho fatto non
ho fatto in tempo a vedere che eravamo
superati i 250 mila e nonostante questo
avevo detto che l'avrei fatto uscire
oggi quindi sabato ma mi è arrivata pure
la febbre quindi ragazzi è stata una
cosa incredibile tanto che siamo a
270.000 sto punto
molti di voi su facebook mi hanno
consigliato di farlo di far uscire
direttamente quello dei 300.000 che
comunque arriverà più o meno all'inizio
dicembre quindi ormai praticamente siamo
lì ragazzi non è che ci parliamo
tantissimo ragazzi della casa e mi
dispiaceva di più e che comunque c'è a
me dispiace non valorizzare diciamo le
tappe migliori ovvero 250.000 iscritti
sono un quarto di milione quindi non
farci un video speciale sopra mi
dispiaceva tantissimo quindi ho trovato
una soluzione che è che molti che a
molti di voi anche piaciuta perché l'ho
scritta sempre su facebook e tecnica già
pagina di facebook però un altro
speciale bonus oltre a quello e quindi
non vi preoccupate perché ne avrete ben
due speciali e tratta ragazzi non avete
idea di che speciali in mente di fare
perché non ho mai fatto cose del genere
ma vi assicuro ragazzi che rimarrete
stupiti perché non ho mai mai mai mai
mai fatto cose del genere e non vi
spoiler o niente comunque raga come
altre news volevo dirvi che la serie su
just dance
diciamo che sta giungendo alla fine
perché ho ballato praticamente quasi
tutte le canzoni ballabili e diciamo che
cercherà di aprire un'altra serie
demenziale che andrà a sostituire
comunque just dance ha pensato di fare
singstar a una serie dove dove io canto
parlano i veri che cazzo postoci fuori
quindi non lo so scrivete hanno comunque
nei commenti se avete delle idee perché
qualcosa devo fare al posto di just
dance ai ragazzi con le news possiamo
concludere qui direi di passare allo
scart aggio dei pacchi e questo episodio
ragazzi vorrei cominciare con una
domanda ma cosa cazzo è
ragazzi non potete inviarmi mai dei
pacchi così grossi ma coesistono cosa
avete inviato il transformer comunque
ragazze ho deciso di aprirne 3 perché
veramente sono diventati troppi se non
ce la faccio più manco ad entrare in
camera mia perché sono troppi non riesco
neanche ad appoggiarli sono scrivania
perché non ci stanno quarto tana allora
riscatto così direi in partire dal primo
ragazzi che è il più piccolo fa vigenti
a d'oro sei un mito continua così grazie
mille partiamo da questo perché è più
facilmente apribile mi sa
[Musica]
madonna è mio zio mezz'ora ok per amare
che la più facile da aprire una falla su
scribblenauts fantastica perché mi avete
inviato una mia foto non ha senso
grazie per questo è bello sto ragazzo
non è fantasma è troppo sexy ma perché
mi avete inviato dal mio posto non ha
senso del mio avatar di una fan art
grazie mille ma invece no la stampante
volendo potevo farlo anch'io comunque
grazie siete faraco se questo è un addio
l'adesivo della nutella non hai vinto
chi che mi ha avviato sap hana torre
saperlo voglio saperlo chi è per fa vj
jesolo scritto per poi vige comunque
grazie mille per fa vj perché mi ha
inviato la cosa che desideravo veramente
di più e l'adesivo con il mio nome della
nutella fantastico questo me l'attacco
al frigo e per ultimo ma non meno
importante mi avete inviato un luigi
perché perché mi avete inviato un luigi
co sa qual è il senso di sto luigi
ragazzi ma noi ci assomigliamo
tantissimo con ragazzi vi ringrazio
tantissimo per avermi a tutta sta roba e
direi di passare al prossimo pacco che
anche questa enorme non capirò mai che
cazzo ci avete da mettere in pacchi così
grandi che un sacchetto di sembra
l'intestino di qualche animale nella
foresta
va beh non importa c'è
[Musica]
ragazzi qualcuno di voi ci ha voglia di
spiegarmi come mai continua tempi armi
la nutella perché non possiamo che
ottimale così giovamento ma che è piena
di nutella maledizione cioè mio team ha
anche guidato sono sempre più grandi
l'ha travolta mi è arrivata quella da un
chilo questa sarà la 10 kg maledizione
che poi tratto sia prestata c'è qualcosa
da c'è pure qualcosa dentro ho trovato
un pool cos'è sta roba
né menez c'è il caso degli e menez sono
non so che che senso può avere comunque
pieni ringrazio per avermi piatto una
nutella la prossima volta che ogni
episodio ogni blog che faccio mi inviato
una nutella sempre più grossa
voglio vedere che cazzo mi inviate come
prossima cosa perché non è possibile è
giunto il momento di scoprire raga che
cosa diamine gel etro sta roba
oddio ragazzo di nome c'è dentro ho
appena visto delle intravisto delle cose
che che vi giuro io sto amando chi mi ha
inviato sto fatto adesso vi dico tutto
abbiamo un cartellone etico con la mia
porto dove sono super sexy e poi ragazzi
abbiamo un altro pacco ce n'è ancora uno
come se non bastasse c'è un pacco nel
pacco becks action ma ci sono due
plettri per la chitarra ancora non so
perché mi avete inviato sta roba nuova
app e quindi avete inviato mirror senso
per playstation 3 mio dio significa che
devo farci una serie su sta roba
noi abbiamo il numero di rosario fanpage
perché mi avete inviato malga e
dopodichè mi avete inviato mirai nichi
l'episodio numero 9 sempre il manga
fantastico c'è questo questo mi
interessa di più i colori prima perché
c'è ma poi mi rainey kg visto l'anime è
fantastico quindi presto me lo metto
sulla mensola grazie infinite un altro
di questi che ci avevo già comunque la
lezione o due
grazie mille perché mi mancava pure
questo è come ultima cosa ci sarebbe
questo parco senz'altro un pacco nel
pacco addirittura navi giorno sono
curiosissimo di vedere che il cazzo va
messo qua dentro perché
nella carta stagnola
[Musica]
muro forse avrebbe occupando meno spazio
nella mia camera se non mi avessi messo
questo pacco finto che ascom occupato
soltanto spazio grazie mille
molto gentile con cave direi di passare
al farmi risponde la prima da quando
ragazzi mi arriva da ralph fiennes buffo
primi scrive a farvi risponde sono stato
io a spiegarti come impostare l'immagine
del tuo account youtube dopo questo mi
posso meritare un succo di frutta alla
pera pavia catania che ti hanno regalato
si chiama tanto ed è un pugnale che
usavano i samurai va a suicidarsi te lo
dico solo per soddisfare le tue
curiosità
[Musica]
dimentichi che parlano i nerd esistere
spam
i ragazzi di concludere qui blog mi
scuso se per caso oggi non sono stato
come negli altri blog
cioè non ho fatto tante scenette o cose
del genere ma veramente raga con la
febbre a registrare veramente
impossibile quindi al massimo il blog è
l'unica cosa che riesco a fare ma molto
più tranquillo del solito perché con la
febbre già un miracolo che sono riuscito
a farlo ma per voi faccio questo ed
altro i ragazzi 6 video è piaciuto come
al solito lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovata una descrizione 60
iscritti iscrivetevi e noi ci rivediamo
un prossimo video ma porca [ __ ] [ __ ]
bella ragazza